you see that video yeah i just watched  it it was awful i can't believe someone  would be hurt like that just because  they're black racism is so unfair no one  should ever judge someone by the color  of their skin i was talking to mrs  mcgrady the other day  she said there's a really long history  of black people not being treated fairly  in this country it has to stop we have  to do something yeah  maybe mrs mcgrady can give us some ideas  i'm so glad you reached out to me yes i  saw the video too  and let me tell you it made my blood  boil why does this keep happening mrs  mcgrady well racism is like a disease if  you don't treat it it's just gonna get  worse okay let me jump in there mrs  grady if i could uh mrs mcgrady whatever  your name is why does it keep happening  well for the same reason that unicorns  keep sitting on your roof  that is it's not happening  like at all